Now, the second of our 3 pillars is going to be
compute performance. And, to get a sense of how your application is
actually spending it's time during a given frame, you really want
to check out the timeline tab inside of Chrome developer tools. How
this works, is that you actually load the timeline, hit this
beautiful record button down here on the bottom, and then watch magic
unfold. So, let's take look at how this plays out with
Biolad Disaster. If I start the game, it goes up very simple.
Now, when I hit the record button down here on the bottom, you
can actually see that it's logging all of the event information that's occurring
while this game is happening. Now, I'm not doing anything, I want to point
that out, yet events are actually being fired. So, let's take a look at
what's actually going on under the hood here. So, if I size this
up, I can actually see the number of events inside of my window
and drill down into what's going on. So, I've an animation frame here.
And if I expand that, you can see that there's actually a request animation
frame that has occurred at that point. Now,
you'll notice down here on the bottom that there's
actually different type of check boxes to filter
out what events you're looking at. And each one
has a respective color. For example, loading is
blue, scripting is gold, rendering is purple and painting
is green. So, if I toggle painting you can
see that those events actually disappear from the timeline.
Now, I did another quick little capture while you weren't looking,
I saw you going to get peanuts from the bag. Now, if
I slide my visibility window to another part of the timeline,
you can see that there's actually a little block here that seems
to be wider than all the other blocks around it, what
this implies is that there's some scripting occurring between our windows here
that is taking longer than the other frames. Now, below us, we
actually have a list of events that occurred, plus as you remember
these little triangles that allows us to drill down into the
event. On here in the side, you can see that we
have the same animation Frame Fire that we saw earlier, but
the new one that we see showing up, is a GC Event,
where 1.4 megabytes of data was actually collected. Hovering over it
brings a popup dialogue that shows you that this actually took
2.7 milliseconds, out of our frame budget to actually do a
garbage collection event. That's why you can see that this block here,
is actually larger then the block next to it, because
we have an extra 2.7 miliseconds that went to do
a garbage collection event. We can actually see this mirrored,
by clicking on the memory option for the timeline. Now, what
this's actually going to show us is a linear graph of
where allocations are actually occuring, and lo and behold, you can
see, between our 2 divets here, when that GC event
occurs, the amount of memory allocated in our application drops down,
thus showing the garbage collection freed memory. Now, I want to show
you what this looks like live, because it's really interesting to watch.
How an application, actually allocates its memory. So, you can see
that over time, this application, when I'm doing nothing on the screen,
is actually allocating about 1 megabyte every second or so. And
then you can see the garbage collector actually kicks in, and frees
a lot of that data. This type of sawtooth pattern that
you're seeing along the timeline here, is very common in different web
applications, that do a lot of dynamic allocation of objects. Now, there's an
article out there that I've written on HTML 5 Rocks, that details different ways
to address this type of sawtooth pattern,
using object pools. But, we're not going to
go into that right now. Let's stay focused on what's in front of us.